a lot of people think that zoos and
aquaria contribute to conservation by
teaching people about the animals and
getting them to care more about the
animals but actually there's absolutely
no evidence for this at all it is
something that zoos and aquaria claim
but it's not backed up by any convincing
data at all in fact one just needs to go
to for instance Japan to see how that is
not the case Japan again is a country
that kills tens of thousands of dolphins
every year and takes them from those
drives and puts them into captivity
Japan has more marine parks than any
other country in the world so although
they have marine more marine parks than
anyone else where their public comes to
see the animals they're also
slaughtering the animals at the highest
rate so those two things don't coincide
going to zoos and conservation don't
necessarily coincide now if you want to
know about dolphins and other animals as
many ways to do that it's too I mean we
have so many media now that can can tell
us what these animals alike also if we
want to we can also very respectfully
try to interact with them in the in the
wild in a natural habitat I can tell you
from seeing dolphins in captivity and
seeing dolphins in the wild that it is
an entirely different experience an
entirely different experience they are
like different animals so once you see
dolphins in the wild it is very very
difficult to be comfortable about seeing
them in captivity
you